So in the,
in the garden of Eden,
there's Adam and Eve,
right?
The primordial human beings,
and there is a walled garden.
That's paradise.
Paradise means walled garden.
An Eden means well watered place.
And so there's this idea that the proper
habitat of human beings is an amalgam of
social structure and nat and nature.
And that's exactly right because that's
what we live in,
right?
We live in,
we never live in nature and we never
live in society.
We live in an amalgam of society and
nature.
That's the human environment.
So it's a walled garden.
All right?
And so it's a productive,
well watered place where we could
thrive.
It's safe and it's ruled over by a
father figure in this particular,
in this particular story.
And that's like the,
you can think about.
That is the spirit of civilization.
That's at least one way of considering
it.
So,
um,
well there's a snake in the garden and
it's there,
unbeknownst to God,
roughly speaking,
although he's,
he knows everything.
So I guess he probably knows about the
snake to and he tells Adam and Eve not
to interact with it,
find.
And they do,
and the snake wakes them up,
right?
Because when they interact with the
snake,
they're given a fruit that opens their
eyes and makes them aware that they're
naked and vulnerable,
and then dooms them to work.
Well,
I'll tell you the whole story much later
in the course,
but I want to give you an overview of it
now,
but then there's this really strange
idea that developed over the course of
the development of not only Christianity
but Judaism and and a number of other
religions that fed into the mainstream
of Christian ideas,
including zoroastrianism.
There's an idea that that emerged across
a very long period of time that the
snake in the garden was the same as
Satan,
the source of all evil.
And as I've been trying to figure out
for the longest period of time,
why in the world the manifestation of
what's essentially a representation of a
predator.
So that's the snake.
And the snake is associated with trees.
Well,
yes.
The reason for that in all likelihood is
that we dwelt in trees,
right?
And snakes like trees and they're around
trees and they can climb trees.
And the snake was a typical Predator on
our,
on our ancient relatives,
but.
And so that's fine.
So you can see that that representation
makes perfect sense.
There's predators that lurk in the
garden.
Yes.
Obviously if you interact with them,
they wake you up.
Well they better wake you up because if
they don't wake you up when you interact
with them,
then you get eaten.
So it's probably just as well to wake up
even though there's painful consequences
associated with becoming conscious.
And that manifests itself immediately in
the story of,
of,
of Adam and eve.
But then there's this weird association.
It's,
it's very undeveloped in the biblical
stories that,
that,
that are part and parcel of this line of
thinking.
It was more like a consequence of a
cloud of mythological stories that
surrounded it.
But the reason for that I think is that
imagine that what human beings we're
trying to puzzle out was the nature of
the Predator.
Okay.
So on one level of analysis,
the predators,
the thing that links along the ground
and the threatens you.
And also it's the thing that's your more
lending me and that wakes you up,
but then that's one conceptualization of
Predator and fair enough you can
identify it and you can take
precautionary measures.
But a better conceptualization of
Predator might be where does it come
from?
Let's say it's a snake,
while there's a layer of snake
somewhere.
And so if we want to get rid of the
snake,
we shouldn't be conceptualizing it as a
we should be conceptualizing it as one
manifestation of a layer of snakes.
And what we should do is go down,
follow the damn snake,
wherever it goes and find it's layer and
wipe out all of the snakes.
And that's,
that's a more abstract representation,
right?
It's not predatory anymore,
it's the source of predation.
And so if you want to solve the Predator
problem permanently,
you don't kill the snake,
you get rid of all the snakes.
Okay?
So fine.
So,
and people are pretty damn good at that.
And that's why you have stories of
people like St Patrick who chased all
the snakes out of Ireland and all sorts
of saints were snake eradication saints.
And well,
there's a variety of reasons for that,
but then you might think,
okay,
well the worst Predator is the layer of
snakes,
right?
But then you might think,
well wait a minute,
the worst Predator isn't the layer of
snakes.
Maybe the worst Predator is the enemies
that come to attack us.
And those are human enemies.
And so what we do is we defend ourselves
against the human enemies.
We put walls around our cities,
we fortify our,
our land,
and we defend ourselves against the evil
that's lurking in other people's hearts.
And so that's like a higher order snake.
And then we build these walls around us
and what's inside gets larger and larger
and larger.
And then what happens is the snake
started popping up inside the cities
because you know,
we pushed all the.
We've,
we've protected ourselves from all the
evil that lurks outside,
but we've now created a space where that
evil can manifest itself inside.
So there's criminals inside the city and
there's people who want to bring you
down.
And there's malevolence within the city,
not only outside.
So then there's the problem of the snake
that's closer to you,
and then there's the ultimate problem,
which is the snake that lives in your
heart,
right?
And that's each individual's capacity
for evil.
And then that was conceptualized as a
transcendent spirit,
right?
So that's the spirit of Satan who's the
WHO's the adversary of the hero,
the adversary of the hero,
and that's why there's an association
between the snake in the garden.
And this is great series of mythologies
about the existence of evil itself.
It's a consequence of our continued
capacity to abstract.
We started using the Predator detection
system to detect snakes and maybe no
predatory cats and maybe birds of prey
and all that,
but that didn't solve the bloody problem
because just because you hid from the
predatory bird today didn't mean the
bloody thing wasn't going to be back
tomorrow and tomorrow starts to matter.
As you get smarter,
and then once you're on that pathway and
you starting to think abstractly about
the Predator,
the nature of what constitutes the
Predator starts to become is because
you're trying to solve that across all
situations simultaneously.
It starts to become very much more
abstracted.
It ends up being something like a
personality,
like an eternal personality,
and in the internal personality that has
its effect on everyone all the time.
So and it's so.
It's so interesting to see those ideas
because they basically evolved.
People did not understand those ideas as
they produced them.
Right?
It was all put forward in a massive
mythological context and in a rich story
context,
and the stories were as conscious as the
information got was never articulated
past the level of story.
So remarkable.
Absolutely remarkable.